in this story from the post millennial
Illinois to force landlords to rent to
illegal immigrants full stop holy crap
is the Third Amendment violation right
well they're not soldiers I guess it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter uh we
had we had a member uh mention this that
the third amendment the spirit of it
goes beyond just the idea of quartering
soldiers because there was a Supreme
Court ruling on it the general idea was
the government could not intrude on your
home
the government forcing you to house
anyone I think would fall into third
amendment so the question would be what
is the spirit of the third amendment and
the idea was the government forcing
people into your homes
but I suppose you could make the
argument it only referred to quartering
soldiers here's a story from the post
millennial illegal immigrants will soon
be granted housing rights in the state
of Illinois after Governor JB pritzker
signed a new bill in law that makes
immigration status a protected class
this means that landlords will not be
able to deny illegal immigrants housing
as average home prices Skyrocket across
the state so it's not like they're going
to the landlords with an illegal
immigrant being like how's them it's
that an legal immigrant will come say I
want to I want to I want to live here
and you can't deny them based on the
fact that they're not citizens which is
kind of crazy because there might be
like other laws you are breaking if you
don't deny them right because what do
you like well they're not citizens can I
run to them you're going to report them
I got I gotta say that is the one thing
where I'm less worried about the whole
story if if an illegal immigrant is
going to find an apartment and someone's
gonna be like I don't want you to live
here do you think they're going to say
well you have to no the landlord's going
to call ICE you should be back here
problem solved there you go but it is
insane they're offering up immigration
status as a protected class do you think
that would there would be repercussions
for calling ice
like do you think breaks the windows or
like could you potentially because our
rule of law gets crazier and crazier all
the time could you get accused of you
know being discriminatory or a hate
crime because you called ice on someone
you suspected was an illegal immigrant
there might be other repercussions by
adding this to being a protected class
depends on where we go as a country yeah
because if we if if depending on who
wins the culture War where we end up in
100 years where it'll change how all of
this is framed and
they already did weren't Democrats
already running ads that likened
arresting illegal immigrants to the same
as rounding up Jews there was like some
viral videos where it showed like the
the image changed or something like that
no what was that all about I think that
might have been something else I don't
know but the Democrats have already
likened immigration detention centers to
concentration camps like an outright
called them that AOC with their fake
photos cry photos crying in front of
these uh these parking lots or whatever
and then claiming that the Detention
Center is put up by Obama were
concentration camps and then as soon as
Trump is out of office they're once
again holding centers you know but so I
guess the question is if you are
somebody who reports an illegal
immigrant you need to ask yourself are
you going to ensure that American values
win the culture War because if you're
not I'll tell you after the far left
extremists win and there's struggle
sessions happening all over they're
going to accuse you of being a Nazi and
they're going to say see this proves it
I think depending on who who wins the
the culture War if it's the far left I
don't even know if we'll have landlords
because it'll probably be BlackRock
owning everything and we'll all be
living in our little 15 minute minute
cities with our and then there's illegal
immigration because there's no borders
we have a global government so maybe
there we go Society collapses quickly
but swiftly yeah the CEO of blackrock's
talking about Bitcoin loving on bitcoin
right now the total great tracking
mechanism that's what he said no he
didn't say tracking mechanism he just
said I I have a lot of Hope for the
future we at BlackRock we we have hope
is one of our main our main tenants and
uh I just want to talk about Bitcoin
because uh it's a hedge against in case
uh I'm gonna stop talking now he didn't
want to like be like well just in case
yeah I heard that yep yeah I feel like
anything that gives BlackRock hope we
should all just be very wary oh yeah if
the CEO BlackRock is saying I care about
Hope and here's Bitcoin I think that
he's telling you if you want to have
hope for the future to get that I don't
know but that's what it feels like is
he's like this is my here's my my get
out of jail free pass do you want it
yeah because I'm talking about Bitcoin
right now or BlackRock this is a lot
like what I think uh Alex Jones is
talking about on the culture World
podcast a few months ago that these
these Elites set a bunch of bear traps
publicly announce where they are and
then sit back and wait and their
mentality is if you're smart enough to
avoid them you then you deserve to avoid
them and if you're stupid enough to walk
into them then you deserve to and so
this sounds very much like that all of
these problems happening all over the
world
in the United States with the problems
especially with like illegal immigration
if you're paying attention to it you are
actively navigating through the bear
traps and for the rest of the people
living in big cities they're walking
straight into them well and you have to
remember that someone benefits from
illegal immigration right they wouldn't
if if we all agreed it was bad and it
didn't help anyone then we would close
the border But ultimately Democrats tend
to like high immigration areas High
illegal immigration areas because they
tend to tip the census to support their
candidates it helps them uh when it
comes to election election years so
think strategically like with Illinois
this is a way to lock down more rural
areas and potentially have more
influence among voters there if you're
if you're making landlords who might not
want to house illegal immigrants in you
know their residences wherever that be
it makes it so potentially
you can gain control over an area
because again you're changing the
demographics of more of the state and I
think that's the problem here I think
that people don't take immigration
seriously because it makes them
uncomfortable taught to talk about like
saying illegal immigration is a
protected class is like saying
it doesn't matter to everyone who tried
to uh migrate here legally because
actually you don't have the same
protections as someone who is illegal
that they're they don't care about legal
immigration they don't care about
upholding the rule of law they care
about getting their way in the end it
feels like Democrats Liberals are just
fire they're consuming and destroying
everything around them well and and
please fact check me but you know
obviously Illinois is more than Chicago
but I went to school in Chicago I lived
basically on on the south side and I
would I would wager that the places that
most of these illegal immigrants are
going to be moving into since if they're
illegal you know how are they working
they're probably not making that much
money they're going to be moving into
the south side of Chicago right where
the cheapest housing is and that's going
to not only create problems but it's
gonna push out people who are living
there so you're all these you know
liberals complaining about
gentrification and meanwhile they're
sort of if you read that last sentence
in Chicago the most populated city in
Illinois the median rent has increased
from 1750 per month to 1900 a month and
it's just so interesting to me if you're
trying to help Chicago residents right
who are getting priced out of being able
to live in their houses getting pushed
out you're now going to add a massive
influx of people that you basically have
to say yes you can live here and if not
you're going to be like accused of a
hate crime it's just it's so backwards
and it there's no way to rationalize
that policy from the perspective of
actually putting Chicago residents you
know mean while when they're not having
like dozens of people die every weekend
because of shootings oh you know what we
should do right now is make sure
Hondurans can live in houses in Chicago
like I mean the biggest argument for
ending Birthright citizenship is
typically this means that you will not
be incentivizing people to cross the
border just by saying if you get here on
time and have a baby here you now have
citizenship and claim to the country and
you could participate in DACA and
everything else and in some ways
Illinois is now saying like we'll do the
same thing if you can get here we're
going to give you special protections
and therefore they are making it likely
that if you were an illegal immigrant
you heard hey well I can definitely I
won't get kicked out in an apartment
because my immigration status which you
know there are benefits to going to
Chicago they're they are making it more
inviting to encourage illegal
immigration which is incredibly
dangerous for everyone involved both the
effect it has on our country but also
for the people who are crossing the
border it's not safe and we shouldn't
encourage it like this uh regarding to
this Chicago thing that they're doing uh
are they charging 1900 a month for rent
for these illegal immigrants or are they
are they being forced to lower their no
right right is probably not connected
however you need to consider that the
more they expand these issues you will
get people who will demand a cheaper
rent and If you deny them they'll make
the argument that it was discrimination
so not typical though I don't think
money plays a big role in this and what
they're going to try and and take this
on is immigration status just means like
if you immigrated this country versus if
you're a citizen citizen or not but of
course it's going to include immigration
status in general which includes
incomplete status or you know expired
etc etc
generally is like when someone is
arrested the board of freely immigration
and if they're releasing the country
like
Immigration Court is so messed up that
you'll have uh years and years before
you're supposed to come back and appear
before a judge you have
no reason to actually return if you're
able to set up life somewhere and live
basically uh away from the system so in
some ways you're potentially hurting
landlords who if someone were to like
commit a crime and flee you know then
their their building is associated with
these negative things I mean I don't
want to be too I don't want to make too
many generalizations but making it so
you are making one state saying illegal
immigration is okay here it hurts
everyone else around them it hurts the
people of Illinois it's not an incentive
it doesn't help or protect immigrants
it's just ultimately creating more fires
that Illinois is going to have to put
out which means they're going to end up
asking the federal government for more
assistance they're already doing that or
the cities the illegal immigrants they
allow into their state move to other
states and then you know California
letting non-citizens in they then go to
Arizona Colorado Etc and they start
putting economic strain in these places
and people aren't they're not being
tracked properly and then they can vote
in terms of like in terms of like
resources to the government to say track
we don't want rights overt surveillance
I mean
the amount of money that being is being
generated by the by the economic
activity of these immigrants is harder
to track and so we're expending more
resources on our Public Utilities
that's just causing costing people more
money yeah I think Adrian Norman for Tim
cassaday just posted an article saying
uh one in four I'm gonna pull it right
now uh nearly one in four public school
students uh are the children of illegal
immigrants or of immigrants generally I
mean immigration has a huge impact on
our country and I know their arguments
for it for some people but
illegal immigration is a a huge
challenge that we are not taking
seriously enough and in fact we haven't
been for years and I think this should
be something that everyone talks about
but instead it becomes this emotional
debate thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time